[Music]
really bad
eggs drink up me hotest yoh
Ho Hey
folks hey goer hey
mag Michael Miss Wicked Wolf Ang
Angus Matt the reader in Black I'm not
going to catch everybody so I'm going to
tell you right now now no Miss Wicked
Wolf I'm not intending to get drunk but
I am going to drink to unwind CU
today
sucked and actually is still in the
process of actively sucking so we'll see
if tomorrow can maybe ease the foot off
the suck pedal just a tad we'll
see it's hard to
know
every day
sucks globally
sure personally no no not everyday
sucks what happened okay well let's deal
with this right up front um for anyone
who didn't already know the review video
that I did for the starbeast the latest
episode Special technically of Doctor
Who Um was blocked by the
BBC now I'm in the process of trying to
get that sorted it's currently unblocked
in the US it's still blocked in the UK
and a bunch of other territories and
it's currently not
monetized um
so let let me let me
explain briefly I'm probably going to do
a full video on this but let me explain
briefly the ins and outs of this and let
me also make it very clear what did not
happen
so the BBC did a claim and a block on my
video specifically claiming the part of
the video where I showed parts of the um
the opening C
while I was praising them oddly enough
um so they claimed that
specifically and
um
interestingly they claimed it on the
basis that it was from the Giggle and
they blocked the video in all
territories now I've dealt with BBC's
nonsense before general rule of thumb
with the BBC is if you are using clips
of less than 10 seconds they leave you
alone that's worked for me very reliably
for a very long time based off what
happened I'm pretty positive I know how
this occurred and it wasn't
malice it was
incompetence because what did not happen
I'm seeing speculation about it already
in comments on various things that I
have out there they did not block my
video because of the warning I have at
the front end of all my Doctor Who
videos about the fact that BBC News is
transphobic that is not what happened so
I want to shut that
down that is not what happened at all it
was claimed by BBC Studios which is a
separate entity and I've had that that
thing up for over two years now and
they've never done this to me before so
what most likely
happened was that in a preemptive effort
to combat any possible leak weeks of
footage from the upcoming specials they
most likely stuck the the Giggle and the
wild blue yonder into YouTube's uh
copyright bot system with instructions
if you see footage from these block it
again probably with the intent to stop
any stuff um ending up online however it
might have gotten there before the stuff
actually airs the problem with that is
they ver if if I'm right and I'm pretty
confident that I am if I am correct then
they didn't take out the opening and
closing credit sequence which means that
anyone who did any commentary on those
and used footage from them suddenly it's
being automatically claimed and blocked
by the system because they didn't think
through what they were
doing
so I am caught up in
bureaucratic idiocy and you cannot get
directly through to a human being so
what I am currently in the process of
doing is so basically I had I had two
realistic options because I wasn't just
going to let this fly well I had three
options but one I was never going to do
I could have just disputed it outright
but that can take up to 30 days so it
could have remained blocked for 30 days
days and um before they did anything
about it so I did not consider
that option two excuse
me option two would have been to edit it
myself in my own editing suite and
re-upload the video and delete the old
one I do not want to do that because
doing that erases the history of the
previous video
you cannot re-upload uh a video and hold
over views comments Etc all that would
suddenly vanish and I don't want to do
that so that left me with the option
that I'm currently in the process of
which
is I have had to use YouTube's
own
um sort of backend CU you can actually
edit in YouTube Studios you can edit
something you already uploaded so I did
that to trim out the bit that they said
they didn't want there um and I ended up
doing it a way that I think the end
result will still be more or less
coherent and isn't missing a ton it's
just missing some of the specifics now
the problem is YouTube's back end when
you edit stuff that way takes
forever to process I submitted these
changes to the
video
oh let me think about 9 hours ago or so
little bit less than that um it's still
processing and so that's not even a
matter of the BBC hasn't responded to
the update the update that I did to the
video still has not worked its way
through YouTube system yet only after
that happens which probably I will not
be able to check until tomorrow morning
only at that point will I know whether
or not that will satisfy the BBC I'm not
positive it will because a different
claim has since popped up on that video
also from the
BBC where they're claiming a different
part of it that actually includes no
footage from the show whatsoever I'm
waiting on that because that might clear
up when the video gets rescanned through
the copyright Bots once the freaking
edit I put through finally
clears but until then I don't know it is
distinctly possible that the work I have
done to fix this won't work anyway
depending on how big a dick the BBC
feels like being about this because
while I do not doubt that the claim
happened because of an automatic process
that does not stop them as a company
from being jerks about clearing it
up so uh this is a shockingly high view
count for viewers on the Stream So
couple things I should not right off I
do try and keep up with the chat um but
I make no promises if you the the way to
guarantee that I will see your comment
or question is to do it as a super chat
which will also get you a heart from me
and on a day like this it would also
lift my
spirits just a
tad but anyways that's the current
standing
on all of that nonsense hopefully it
will be sorted in the morning and I can
pretty
much
uh
guarantee that when I do the next two uh
Doctor Who specials I will use literally
no footage and my videos will be worse
for it
but I'm bitter and ticked off and not in
the mood to mess with it right
now uh sucks from what you've said it's
your biggest source of traffic I mean
not 100% of the time but that video it
was on track to at least have a shot at
being my best performing video of the
year and that's the other thing even if
I get this sorted and
fixed this entire thing will have killed
its momentum dead because as far as the
algorithm is concerned it's the thing
hit a brick wall it's not like the
algorithm is going to pick it up where
it left off once it clears everything
again it'll basically be starting from
zero all over again so all algorithmic
momentum will be gone even if I get this
fixed so view wise it's probably just
going to sit where it's at and just
creep up a little beyond that even if I
can clear
it I recommended a video where someone
was claiming the special was transr of
course they freaking
were
oh Erin o thank you very much for the
Super Chat I greatly appreciate that
love the Doctor Who review it's still
available in Canada well um anyone who
feels like firing up a VPN I guess if
you feel like being Canadian for 44
minutes you can watch the
video shotguns and salt what a great
name um no comment just the Super Chat
will you get a heart from me regardless
on
that Hypno Amber for emotional and
physical labor big hugs thank you yeah
it's today has
been
exhausting and like this kind of stuff
is
just really irritating thank you Miss
Wicked Wolf this one came off and I
haven't done this hand yet I got to
figure when I'm going to do that I don't
know for some reason I didn't have the
uh the energy to do to do the rest of my
nails today can't imagine why
not uh since we'll never see it in the
video game what did you in the video
again what did you think of the new
opening titles oh I loved them I thought
they were phenomenal and like some a lot
of my praise is still in the video even
with the edit just I had had some visual
signifiers there referencing some of the
specific things I especially liked but
the fact that I liked it will still be
there assuming that this this Ed it
clears we'll see Supreme Omega I will
always roll that R I don't even know if
you like it when I do it but I will
always do it uh on the separate the art
from the artist debate do you find it
frustrating and depressing that so many
artists that you like turn out to be
terrible people yeah it's
frustrating it's frustrating and and
slightly depressing especially if you
yourself are a creatively inclined
person odds are a lot of the most
inspiring figures in your life are going
to be creative people and when you take
in something that's a creative work and
like I'm not trying to sound Superior
like if you also do creative works well
you're just a better audience that's not
what I mean but like it hits different
because it's not just a matter of well
that entertained me it's much more
likely if you are also a creatively
minded person which I am that you took
inspiration from this person so it
wasn't just like a fun thing to pass the
time it was a bit more meaningful than
that and so it hurts more when they turn
out to
just
suck
and yeah like my uh for anyone new here
and geez like I said a lot of people in
the chat a lot more than I'm used to on
a standard Tuesday um my general thing
with separating the artist from the
artist the broadest thing that I can say
is that you can't um I actually think
it's disrespectful to the art to pretend
that it came that it exist in a vacuum
it wasn't created by human beings who
poured their own thoughts life
experiences and unfortunately sometimes
prejudices and biases into a piece of
work in terms of specifically supporting
an artist that is a much more moot point
when we're talking about an artist no
longer alive like say HP Lovecraft be
aware and watch out for the racist
inclinations in his work but you don't
have to worry about buying any of his
stories the Man's dead he can't cause
any harm um if somebody is still around
and you're financially benefiting them
then take into consideration what may be
done with that money or what your
financial support of them might uh say
to them not I'm not saying necessarily
what it says about you but what it might
say to them in the idea of oh well
people are still okay with me if you're
actually not okay with them and that's
not me saying you can't support anybody
you don't like we'd never be able to
watch anything ever again if that was
the case but like just be
aware yeah and also going off just just
just just leaning into the tangent uh
separating the artist from the art is
different from Death of the author death
of the author has to do with the reading
into the meaning of a piece of work you
are entitled to read your meaning into a
piece of work and it can be completely
separate from what the author intended
that's a completely separate thing from
the notion of separating the artist from
the art for the purposes of what I'm
what I was just talking about there we
go ah got some new super chats in
greatly appreciate it today folks it is
it's it's been a thing Donna oh Kathy n
sorry cannot forget to say who it was
thank you so much Donna got programmed
like buggy even though it might have
killed her men can't let things go lazy
writing all over did not help the show
at all I broadly speaking disagree I
think I mean
okay I'm not going to reiterate my
entire review um so so let me just
bullet points in regards to the kinds of
things
that um you have laid out first of all
that sequence of words used to deprogram
her like that was never a sequence of
words that was going to be said by
accident like is it a bit of a Trope in
terms of brainwashing and spy related
things yes absolutely if you don't like
it as a Trope cool but like that wasn't
a sequence of words that was going to be
said by one person unbroken without
interruption so it that that I don't
personally understand the hangup unless
you don't you just don't like the Trope
which fine um but I I don't feel the
writing was especially lazy it wasn't as
focused in all areas as I would have
liked I had my own uh issues and notes
and critiques on the thing um I didn't
think it was perfect I had a couple of
hiccups but like the writing
is it's RTD it's RTD writing Doctor Who
and I also said this in the review while
I have
hopes um and I kind of I really want
when we get to shiwa that he's going to
bring something new to the table that
he's going to bring a different energy
bring a different feel bring a different
intent to it I am willing at the at the
present time to accept that these three
specials with tenant are a nostalgic
celebration and so while I don't want
shudy goa's tenure to feel exactly like
um series 1 through 4 I am more okay
with these specials feeling very much
like seasons 1 through 4 which to me
they did now again if you don't like
series 1 through 4 um or you don't feel
they've aged well or whatever else
Fair absolutely fair but for me
I I got wrapped up in it which is what I
needed it to do I needed it to wrap me
up in the fun and the excitement and the
Nostalgia of it and it did that so as
far as I'm concerned it did its job um
again is it all perfect no like I said
there are multiple things that I take
issue with some of the writing and some
specific things being not clear where
they really needed to be but not in a
way that ruined it for me and like it
can frequently happen that
um I'll watch something and like
there'll be the little things that annoy
me it is equally possible I've had to go
both ways that with time the little
things that like bug me just feel like
they don't matter anymore but it's also
happened uh with equal frequency that
the things that that doesn't sit quite
right bother me more and more and more
and more as time goes on so we can go
either way but going off initial
impression you know just a matter of
days from when I saw it it did its
job okay we've got more
super chats Stardust thank you very much
uh I've had a tiring day being angry at
trans Healthcare in the UK uh yes from
my understanding that is something that
would Stoke a lot of incredibly valid
anger so I hope the Super Chat lifts
your mood as much as this stream Has
Lifted mine thank you Stardust I
appreciate that greatly and I hope that
you are able to navigate that nonsense
with the most efficiency that can be
managed by a human human being which
unfortunately in its current state is
probably not a lot
but so is the state of things Jake
Ratcliffe thank you very much for the
Super Chat I watched it and we'll do it
again as I loved it oh lovely thank
you
uh am I going to see Wonka probably not
I haven't been to the movies hardly at
all this year and oddly I don't miss it
as much as I thought I would
maybe part of it was like when when I
was in my previous relationship we'd go
to movies together and none of uh the
relationships I'm in right now is that a
major feature like it it happens
intermittently but it's not it doesn't
feel like uh o that's something we can
do it doesn't come up as often and there
was very little this year that I was
like got to rush out to the theater and
see that
so yeah not not a lot of excitement in
the movie theater or the idea of going
these days and I don't know how much of
that is me and just where I'm at right
now and how much of that is
um just the movie is not exciting me
like I saw some things in the theater I
took my kiddo to see the new Ninja
Turtles I went to uh across the
spiderverse with uh with my boyfriend so
you know there was there has been stuff
just not a lot and it's really rare for
me to go alone
anymore uh stream where I like did a
stream about mix rice couple yesterday
and reminded me of a story about my
grandmother that I found funny she was a
pretty bigoted woman but a member of my
extended family named her great great
granddaughter after
her uh I
mean you you get you get back into older
generations and yeah you usually hit
that eventually I mean kind of the best
you can hope for sometimes is it's the
ones that uh you know personally aren't
like that and it's just a matter of like
the generations that you didn't even
meet so that's if you're lucky all right
I had more Super chats uh what do we got
uan thank you very much for the Super
Chat the Beast one is still up in
Australia which is good because there's
no legal way to stream anything else
Doctor Who here except the new special
oh you're one of the ones that got lost
through the cracks there's a number of
places like that Ireland really got
screwed from my
understanding yeah sir Jedi Sentinel
hello there my friend sucks about the
video F the BBC y cheers to
that I just want to say I finished the
prisoner and I'm ready and hyped to hear
Jesse's thoughts in two
weeks I don't think people will be let
down like that episode so again for
people who are new here we're talking
about uh the Council of Geeks podcast
feed now where along with Jesse jender
uh she and I been going through every
episode of the uh British series The
Prisoner and we've we have actually
finished like we finished we watched and
we recorded um not only our thing on the
last episode but like a general wrapup
video uh with a special guest so that'll
be fun so I already know what she had to
say about it but you folks won't find
out uh for a few weeks but yeah the PRI
prisoner a
trip it's something
sorry again really need to
shower yeah have have a good have a good
cleanse
ah let's
see uh raps City in blue
111 or 11 or
101 could say that any number of ways
raps City in Blue uh can't wait for MPH
that's Neil Patrick Harris uh he is
great stage presence I generally enjoy
him when I see him and stuff he was
quite good in the fourth Matrix movie
which you all seem to have decided
doesn't exist which is unfair that movie
is pretty good I'd rewatch that one
before I would rewatch The Third One to
be completely
honest my favorite prisoner episode is
Hammer into
Anville interesting choice
I many have Happ returns has a good shot
at being my
favorite I don't care how you say the
numbers cool just making a thing out of
it yeah was my favorite Matrix sequel I
actually think that
reloaded is pretty good but it's
hampered by the fact that it doesn't
have an ending of its own and just leads
into the weakest of the four movies um
but I do think reload is decent it's
just unfortunately because of the split
nature of the narrative it's the kind of
decent that gets weakened if the thing
it's attached to doesn't hold up which
unfortunately was the case do I speak
Spanish no I barely speak English what
are you
kidding uh where's the
ah let's finish this
off there we go
go anybody curious tonight's water is
wring imported from
Germany oh
shits I'm sorry oh
shist sorry nobody heard me say
that
H okay there we
go
and Gabriel Navaro also sent in a Super
Chat no comment but I appreciate it all
the
same reing country represent yay yeah I
thought you'd appreciate that goer reing
kind of is my go-to at this point I like
sweeter wines and it's it's it's a good
safe bet for me it would be hesitant it'
be an overp to say that it's my favorite
wine but is the most reliable like if I
go to a resta or whatever and they're
just serving all this stuff and I'm like
I don't know what it o reing I know that
and I know I like it it's like it's like
good reliable
tasty that's a cool sweatshirt thank you
this this particular
hoodie uh done by Grim Noir who's a
friend of
mine before excuse me before I plug
there um before I plug their site I want
to make sure that it's still up and
running because I know they were yeah I
think they've currently paused it so I'm
not going to plug it um because they've
paused doing work but the this a friend
of mine designed this so um I I have a
number of hoodies that they
designed any thoughts on Indie animation
I find there's been a Resurgence on
YouTube I mean that's such a broad term
I don't I wouldn't know where to start I
like animation in general I'm a I'm a
big fan of Animation as an art form
certainly I have an ethical dilemma I've
been meaning to ask you oh
dear o that's a that's
um that that's feels like a loaded
leadup we'll
see uh here's a funny thing I leared
today I'm rewatching the late 80s BBC
adaptation of the Narnia books I
remember watching those on PBS the actor
who played Mr Beaver is also Nimrod in
the Sandman oh
Nifty so let's
see the star Beast was like nostalgic
bowl of mashed potatoes there were a few
hard lumps that didn't get mashed enough
but it was still tasty and
comforting that's that's that's a decent
uh that's a decent way to put it couple
of questions I'm also CU about favorite
Batman and if you have a show coming
up well Meg um favorite liveaction
Batman is Michael Keaton favorite Batman
in
general it's probably Kevin
Conroy Jeremy CYO did it pretty good as
well um and that's
animated um shows coming up yes I do um
I am hosting a burlesque show at Main
Street Landing in Burlington Vermont on
Saturday
the 9th so not this coming Saturday but
the one after um I will not be
performing a ver lless number but I will
be uh co-hosting that show that's a
Green Mountain cabaret show so anybody
who happens to be in or within driving
distance of Burlington Vermont on the
9th get tickets it's liable to sell
out it's your funeral may be my favorite
prisoner episode because it's got both
Darren nbet and Mark Eden who are both
in the Marco Polo Doctor Who Cal which I
love see I only recently found out
actually earlier today I found out that
uh that they were in that I haven't seen
that
one want some absence 70% no the one
time that I indulge in absin
it it uh was it was messy well
let's let's go with that um like I I did
I did like it uh but it's I'm I'm not
I'm not sure that's a that was a good
idea for me serenity Productions thank
you very much for the Super Chat just
wanted to say I love you you're one of
my favorite YouTubers and really help me
figure out my gender identity keep up
the amazing
work thank you Serenity Productions I
appreciate
that uh as an OG fan of Council of Geeks
I look forward to the reviews of Doctor
Who
as a great second part to watching the
latest episode L your your review hope
this doesn't stop you thank you very
much James I appreciate
that any progress on my centuri
bres no no
that's I forgot I'd idly said
that um have you seen the grifter Shrine
claim the ratings are terrible was the
biggest drama launch of the year they
really love lying I hate talking ratings
I don't want to see them I don't want to
I like I have I have indulged that
conversation
whoa ah
right that was a reminder I have to
check in on the Discord in a hot second
but let me finish the thought
um I I have indulged the topic of
ratings I think twice I don't like
talking about it largely because I don't
care I don't care what the ratings are
to me that proves nothing there are
great shows that have terrible ratings
there are terrible shows that have great
ratings to me because I care about my
own thoughts on Doctor Who and the stuff
in general it's pretty rare for me to
care what the ratings are if it's
something I like the degree to which I
care is are the ratings good enough for
it to not be canceled if the answer is
yes that's good enough and I don't care
so I hate talking about ratings and I
try to avoid it if I possibly
can uh I guess we excuse me I guess we
should wait until all three specials air
but do you detect the difference between
the 10th and the 14th so far I can tell
14th is less cocky than 10 like a little
it's not very pronounced so far uh
hopefully I'll have a better sense by
the time they're done so shotguns and
salt I will come back to your Super Chat
what I need to do first is
I need to pop on over to the um Council
of Geeks Discord which is uh a patreon
exclusive perk for the Council of Geeks
patreon if you didn't know but um aside
from the super chats here there is a
channel over there to ask questions that
I will address on stream that's the one
other way to guarantee that your
question gets addressed so I got to go
over there and check that let me see
this real quick my question is would it
be
wrong to use Heim or refer to wait I
missed the first part of your question
okay hold on uh there's this person who
I'm suspect isn't is n really trans
needless to say they seem to fulfill The
Stereotype phobes Claim about bathrooms
not helped by uh some stuff that they
did ah okay um so basically the short
answer
is unless you have actual evidence to
support and I don't know the specifics
of this situation but unless you have
actual evidence to support the idea that
this person does not sincerely
identify um as trans or binary or
whatever else it is best to just go with
the preferred pronouns because if
they've done something awful just deal
with that for the time being like this
brings back flashes of Ezra Miller
because I know I know all of us myself
included would love for Ezra biller to
not be part Ezra Miller to not be part
of our community but that doesn't make
it okay to misgender them because that's
just not a thing we should be doing at
all so that's my general stance I don't
know enough about the specifics about
this maybe there is enough to um you
know that other than just like disgust
at what this person uh may have done
that makes you believe no but like I
would still say even if you're not going
to honor the gender identity don't like
make a statement out of misgendering
them because that is to do that is
harmful so even because I know there are
people who even say about Ezra Miller I
think that Ezra Miller fakes the gender
identity that they claim you know to to
be a jerk or to feel special or whatever
even if you sincerely believe that
making a show of misgendering them that
in and of itself making a big deal about
doing that is harmful to the trans
community no matter who the heck you do
it to so that's sort of where I stand
with that I got to pop over to the
Discord I'll be back as soon as I can
all right let me get through these quick
as I can oh there's a few
okay when I was a kid I used to play in
this space next to a Cricket Club my dad
used to play at occasionally it was
wooden and I pretended it was Jurassic
Park oh cute the other day I asked my
dad if he could remember me going to
that Woodland area and make believe
Jurassic Park he told me he could not
but uh he had no idea which Cricket Club
I was thinking of do you have any
childhood memories like that I mean it's
a thing you super cherish are super
nostalgic for but your parents don't
remember at all like I'm sure to my mom
and dad it was like our six-year-old is
running around the trees at the edge of
the field leave him to it I mean
probably I don't I don't know those
kinds of memories I tend to hold just
hold on to for myself because I don't
want to question them and I don't want
to run the risk of somebody going I
don't remember that or that's not what
happened so I don't know it isn't even a
conscious choice I think instinctively I
tend to like hold that stuff to myself
and not like try and get verification of
it uh should Rose Noble become a
companion in my opinion yes will she
probably not but I would like that um
recently I rewatched your review of
excession that is a novel by i m banks
for folks who don't know you said the
afront are one of your favorite aliens
in the culture Universe I wondered if
you'd agree with my interpretation that
the fact that the afront is likable is
kind of one of the most Insidious things
about them like you know men who are
kind of fun to be around if you're not
one of the groups they dislike because
they're funny and good to have a beer
with but also have kind of intensely
bited views anyway thought the afront
were meant to be taken to its ultimate
extreme they're fun at parties but they
deliberately still use slaves even
though the culture offered them nons
sapian drones they could do the same
work yeah i' actually said it's a pretty
good analysis of the affront as a
species you know they're they're vibrant
and jovial but also kind of terrible so
like it is they are the kind
of alien species or characters or what
have you that I like to read about but
would never want to actually encounter
cuz like oh I'd hate
you uh next up do you think a union for
YouTube creators would be a good idea to
address and fight
the bullshirt YouTube comes up with
regularly um maybe it's not realistic um
like trying to
unionize because there's no
there's it it's open doors to start
youtubing so one of the things that is
sort of the nature of Union is um you
know properly organizing these people
but when it's when it's an Open Door
system and anybody can just walk in and
start doing the work of a YouTuber how
you even logistically form a union is
difficult aside from the fact that I
don't think there is enough political
will amongst a majority of YouTubers to
form one anyway broadly speaking unions
are good they're helpful would it help
probably will we ever have one no no we
won't do you personally consider Doctor
Who comic relief and children need
specialist to be Canon depends on the
nature of the special like uh the curse
of the Fatal death clearly not canon um
here's the thing I've never prior to the
most recent children of need special the
one with Davos prior to that I never
really had to consider whether or not
they Canon because it didn't matter
before if that makes sense like there is
no actual larger implications to time
crash or to time and space like the the
multi-part thing with with Rory and Amy
or uh Knight and the doctor as opposed
to Knight of the doctor there are no
actual deep canonical ramifications to
those you can take them or you can
ignore them and it doesn't really matter
whereas the Davos thing potentially
depending on whether it comes up again
which it might not and if it never does
then this will fall in that same
category but at least has the potential
to affect Canon away none of the others
did so I never really had to consider
whether or not they're Canon thinking
about it by and large yeah I expect most
of them are if only because there's no
reason for them not to be uh can you
briefly explain why so many fans dislike
the half-human Twist from the Doctor Who
movie doesn't it kind of make sense for
him to be half human given how much time
he spends on
Earth so I can only tell
you my issue with it I wasn't watching
Doctor Who when that TV movie came out
so I can't speak for other fans I think
in a lot of cases the impression that
I've gotten from fans who dislike it is
kind of for a similar reason why some
people dislike the Timeless child this
not the reason I dislike the CH Timeless
child even though I do dislike it a lot
but like some people just really take
offense to something that core to a
character that that essential to the
understanding being messed with they
just find that distasteful as a thing to
do um and I think the having the doctor
kiss the companion was responded to
similarly by a lot of people now is that
the reason I don't like that twist no I
don't like that twist because why
freaking why
and I think anything that further
explains the doctor Beyond us Beyond us
watching his actions I don't want it's
that's also part of a big part of why I
don't like the Timeless child I don't
care where the doctor came from I don't
care what his childhood was like I don't
care who his parents were I don't care I
care about what the doctor does I care
about watching this character seeing
them get out there into the universe
have Adventures rescue people I don't
care and I actually enjoy the fact that
so much is unknown about the doctor cuz
it's like the show agrees with me that a
full history of who this person was
prior to when the show started doesn't
matter it doesn't matter so forget about
it so anytime something kind of tries to
insert that info I'm like why is this
here we don't need it so for me it's
it's distracting and frustrating I've
noted elsewhere I'm not a lore person in
general I don't like lore like
lore existing is fine I don't care about
lore though I care about story I care
about plot I care about narrative I
don't really care about lore so when
stuff like that comes up it feels like
lore being shoved in my face and I
aggressively don't care and so it
frustrates me on principle so that's
where I'm at can't speak for anybody
else given how uh given how positively
season season five was received now
everything build up to the next season
do you think it's possible for strangers
things six to live up to the hype season
five there hasn't been a season five has
there I think you're off by a
number yeah you're off by a number okay
so I'm gonna I'm G to move it back one
number piece and assume you're talking
about season 4 and how everything build
builds up is it possible for season
things season
[Music]
things stranger things season five to
live up to the hype um certainly not for
me I didn't like stranger things season
4 actually there are some aspects of
stranger things season 4 that I freaking
hate I did not like it very much at all
first one is still by far the best one
third one is the next one and I don't
know between four and two two is just
kind of dull four has some bits that are
great and a lot I hate so I don't know I
don't but like broadly speaking no
probably not you know with how long time
is between seasons for that show I think
the height buildup is probably going to
bite them in the butt as far as the
general reception goes aside from the
fact that for them to do uh a fifth
season even It's the final one it's
going to have to build off of The
Narrative choices of season 4 which in
my opinion at least were bad narrative
choices and I don't think you can build
a particularly good or interesting story
or satisfying one off the back of that I
think it's going to be kind of bad I
think it's going to wind up being
ultimately pretty generic and not feel
anywhere near as unique is when it
started that is my prediction broadly
speaking speaking of someone who did not
like stranger things season 4 there are
reviews up in my secondary channel the
break room of Geeks if you want to know
the reasons behind that okay sadly
almost today's streams as I have worked
sorry to hear that sorry you couldn't
make it all right we're we're we're
getting there I gotta I gotta burn
through these
okay Mecca giant robot genre yay nay or
me which medium suits the genre the best
uh me I not I'm not particularly
invested nor do I have a problem with
giant robot Mecha I haven't seen a ton
of it that has grabbed me that much I
don't like Pacific grandm M that much
one of my favorite animes is technically
that vision of esaf um but I did rather
like the um more medieval fantasy
setting of that it was less of a Sci-Fi
setting for some reason that worked
better for me any opinion on the current
state of tabletop RPGs I I don't no I
don't have an opinion on the broad state
of tabletop RPGs because I don't keep
enough uh I don't keep up with it enough
I like playing D and D that's where I'm
at what is the weirdest yet awesome
comic literature thing I've read lately
I don't know I haven't read anything in
a little bit I just I'm so behind on so
much trying to remember the last thing
that I read or listened to on
Audible
ah I don't I don't know I don't know I I
would have to sit here for the next 10
minutes to come up with an answer and
people are already waiting back in the
main chat not a question but I wanted to
share the news that kosa got delayed I
hit how this piece of news behind the oh
okay so kosa if people didn't know the
kids online safety act it's one of those
pieces of legislation that sounds good
and maybe even has good intentions
behind it but in its current state is a
really bad piece of Law and I don't
personally trust uh Congress as it
exists to make a good piece of law
trying to address that uh in a way that
wouldn't just be a nightmare there are a
lot of problems with the current state
of the co uh kab Bill one of the big
ones being it is worded in such a way
that it would
basically have the potential to shut
down lgbtqia plus people from existing
on the freaking
internet so yeah it's a bad piece of
legislation that if I'm being generous
has a sincere desire to deal with some
of the problems and things that are
being taken advantage of kids but
honestly I think we're going to have
more luck with all these State Attorneys
General that are currently suing meta
for harvesting kids data I think we're
going to get farther that way than
trying to craft a law especially with
the current Congress cuz it's a mess any
thoughts on the Stoess SL Blitz
relationship in hell of a boss I
honestly appreciate the messiness but a
lot of people find it too toxic here's
the thing about that relationship it is
a little bit toxic but it's also the
healthiest relationship either of those
characters is in so I feel like if
you're going to view that and criticize
it as a toxic relationship you kind of
have to look at it in a vacuum because
for both of them it's a step towards um
better healthy relationships and should
they continue to do even better than
they are doing with each other yeah
probably but for where those two
characters are in their life right now
yeah it's it's probably the best thing
that happened to either of them in a
while H season 4 is my favorite season
of Babylon 5 looking forward to the
podcast getting into it okay other quick
thing about the podcast for people who
don't already
know um I did say that we were that
Jesse and I were looking at the prisoner
we started looking at the prisoner
because of the uh actors and writers
strike and on 5 was was a struck show so
we didn't cover that but the strike is
now over and we're wrapping up our
coverage of uh the prisoner so we will
resume Babylon 5 coverage we are in the
middle of season 4 was where we left off
so that'll pick back up again in the new
year um are you finding the heavier
serialization helps in playing to the
series strength uh EG jettisoning some
of the comedy B plots yeah I think the
show very much um is it's add its
strongest when when it leans into the
serialization more and and a story feels
like it is built on the back of
something that came before whether it's
the immediate prior episode or not you
said the campy aspects of rtds who
writing don't always work for you did
you enjoy them in Star Beast I mean it's
a special and the specials tend to be
campier like okay let me put it this way
in regard specifically to the camp
aspects of the special if this had been
the tone of episode one of shoy gotwa um
series I would be complaining about it
more but I kind of go into the specials
particularly an RTD pen special
expecting a certain amount of Camp
because that's just his Baseline so I
kind of prepped myself for it did I
enjoy them that might be an
overstatement did they bother me no but
because I was expecting them um we're
almost done big boss has two hearts
Omega would have two hearts but so would
the Ronnie oh okay so the referencing uh
the Meep referring to the boss uh and uh
the possibility of somebody having two
hearts ah H I don't know I don't do
speculation I suck at it Omega would be
viable the Ronnie it's never the Ronnie
it's like it's never the Ronnie watch it
turn out to be the Ronnie this one
freaking
time I mean the master would be another
obvious
go-to um Romana
rason barusa you want to do a deeper cut
there's
options um in terms of building a
universe Al Marvel why do you think that
people forget that Marvel start was
actually pretty ropey Iron Man was Sol
but the next two installments Hulk
attempt one and Iron Man 2 were either
ignored or forgettable in the key movie
and establishing the MCU could be a
thing was actually probably Thor
unfashionable as it is to like that film
I mean the thing is this is a problem
with both audiences and Studios is they
look at the end result of what Marvel
built in this huge big thing and they
forget that yeah it built up relatively
slowly certainly compared to how fast
everybody else is trying to ramp up into
a shared universe and yeah it had
stumbling blocks but the those get those
kind of call it survivors bias those
those fade away and we just remember
everything that worked and yeah that's
kind of a hazard if you're trying to
move forward with your own plans
inspired by the Loki Pie
scene what exactly is a keyme pie and
what does it taste like it tastes I
don't I don't know what's in it I can't
make one it tastes like
think something kind of in the
neighborhood of consistency to a
cheesecake but it kind of tastes like
lime flavored
Jell-O I like
them there we go I am caught up on uh
all of those which means I am back now I
got to see what super chats have come in
oh a fair few okay now I got these John
vinyls thank you very much uh regarding
Matrix Revelations it does annoy me when
good stuff gets ignored because of how
it was distributed for example I love
the 2019 sl222 Green Eggs and Ham series
on Netflix and the
film uh Fay Fel I've never heard of that
I saw a little bit of the green eggs in
ham it was interesting but um it was
also one of those things I was trying
out to see if my kiddo would like it and
they weren't hooked so I pass on it but
it seemed interesting enough um who's up
next jar jar Ed what happens if we do
ever get a Canon episode called The
Curse of the Fatal
death I'll deal with it when it happens
I suppose
that's one of those things like I don't
know I I can't even begin to wrap my
brain around that idea Serenity
Productions thank you once again have
you heard the rumor that palagan doctor
is getting a spin-off what of your
thoughts I think it's a bad idea I think
it is a bad idea to have running in
parallel another version of the doctor
your like fan Wars are things that's
going to happen regardless cuz the fan
base is freaking exhausting and always
has been um
but but I don't think you help
especially with the current state of the
of this particular fan base as it is by
inviting a division by splitting the
fandom and offering them two different
versions of the doctor especially one
that's going to feed into all the people
who say oh it needs to be like the old
stuff I feel like you're just leaning
into stoking just all the infighting I
don't think it's a great idea if they
wanted to do a special starring Manan I
could get behind that I think an actual
fullon spin-off I I
just I can't imagine it's going to be
any better than what he has done with
big Finnish for years and I can't
imagine it's going to be worth it in the
end
so uh where was I oh Supreme Omega oh
thank you it turned into doofen merch
there for a
second a Super Chat Parry the Super
Chat ah in the
80s oh sorry on the80s I wonder why the
decade continuously produced so much
nostalgic callbacks what makes 80s more
valued in pop culture than any other era
um
so part of it it's okay it's a couple of
things the first is we hit the standard
Nostalgia cycle which is usually between
10 and 30 years um it is now caught up
to the '90s and we are starting to see a
certain amount of '90s
nostalgia um but also part of it is is
that a lot of the big creatives in um
media right now they are um they are gen
xers Andor Elder Millennials and while
you might think Elder Millennials would
have more Nostalgia for the 90s um a lot
of them especially if they had older
siblings have very fond thoughts about
the 80s so I think the 80s as a
Nostalgia cycle is holding on a little
longer than his standard but I think I
think it's already crested I think we're
on the tail end of that overall
um and and it's and I think if you're so
why is it more valued I don't know if
it's more valued it's more memorable
because it's it's it's very unique if
you hear 80s music you're like that's
80s music you see 80s fashion you go
that's 80s fashion you see 80s TV yeah
that's 80s TV it it everything felt very
of the time which made it dated
immediately but it also means that it
makes it more unique uh and specifically
identifiable
um so where where else are we Oli
Tomlinson music thank you for the Super
Chat hello longtime viewer love your
videos thank
you um Mr Cool
210 hello there don't know why why I got
slight flirty voice with that I don't
know why I did that but it's a thing I
did and I'm leaning into it now do you
think anything interesting could happen
in public culture or storywise when
doctor who becomes public domain aside
from the obvious horror film uh that
kind of turned into um hetrick warber at
the end though yeah it's the poison for
Cusco cusco's poison
um I mean yeah potentially I think
public domain is a great thing
creatively like everyone's like oh
you'll just get a flood of bad stuff
yeah and the good stuff will rise to the
top why do you think we still have
Sherlock Holmes why do you think we
still have Dracula yeah there's a lot of
crap but the good stuff stands out I
think it will be a good thing I I I
think public domain as a general thing
is good creatively it is a good thing
and yes somebody will make a horror
version where the doctor is just like
kidnapping people or something there was
gonna be a version of Peter Pan that was
that I don't think that ever got made
I've lost track they keep trying to
remake Peter Pan they've all been
garbage
too public domain can also result in
garbage but so can everything else
Louise now my brain's going on Bob's
Burgers oh Louise honey what's your
question there uh are you looking
forward to Wild are are you more are you
more looking forward to wild blue yonder
or the giggle um I was just sad that
Kate wasn't in the first episode also
did they write out o good I don't know
enough about either one of those to have
a preference like all I really know is
the title I haven't been following the
rumors about what may or may not be in
each one because I don't want to know in
advance so I can't really say I'm
looking forward to more to one or the
other
um did they write out OSG good no no OSG
good is still around as is a zygon
version version of ozg good but the
character has not been touched on in
some time um but she's still around um
well she kind of she appeared in the um
lonely assassins uh game which was
pretty
good yeah if they want to do more with
her I would not complain Mike Burns SL
arranged
accidents is that like your official job
you arrange
accidents if you want somebody gone you
don't want to wait too long called the
immediate professionals okay moving
on you have the most objective takes on
newo out there uh here's a classic
recommendation for you Friday the 13th
the series no relation to the movies
other than the title fonts think
Warehouse 13 I've heard of that um I've
never checked it out they did that with
a few things they did that with
um oh
crap what was it h
there was another show that like had the
name of a horror franchise of a horror
movie franchise but it was just like
um it was like tracking down artifacts
or something it was like nothing like
what the what the movie was I can't
remember what it was now but like there
were a couple like that um I I don't
it's funny I don't try and be objective
like the the notion of an um
objective
uh the notion of an
objective review is like a a silly
notion thanks for for catching that
person um goer I appreciate that
um because like no review can be
objective if your opinion isn't in there
then it's not a review the only things
you can review objectively are things
that are Pur mechanical like you can
objectively review a vacuum cleaner you
cannot objectively review a piece of art
because part of the function of art is
to create an emotional uh impact and you
have to comment on that whether it
worked for you or not you have to
comment on that you can't be objective
but I think the reason I sometimes read
that way is because I don't I'm not
looking to paint Doctor Who or really
too much of anything with so broad a
brush as like this is all good this is
all bad I
like finding the bit the bits of good
that are in you know some of the rough
stuff like there are legitimately great
episodes during uh the Chris chel era
not a lot but there are some and also I
I want I want to be sure to not just
effusively praise like I think sometimes
I will get so wrapped up in liking a
thing I'll be like there are some
problems but I don't want to dwell on
them because sometimes that does happen
but like nothing is perfect so I think
just the way my brain works which tends
to be
um the the general way my brain works
tends to be just a matter of well here's
all the good stuff here's all the bad
stuff and I tend to talk about both so I
I think the result is it feels more
objective because maybe it feels more
balanced yeah I I I do my best even when
I have a strong response be it negative
or positive I I also try and give some
Credence to uh
alternating views if I can wrap my head
around them um because sometimes I I
can't and I'll cop to that too jar jar
Ed coming on back we are going to be
wrapping up soon I appreciate it though
having gone through all the big finish
Doctor Who audios with Charlie I am now
a pretentious hipster Paul manan's my
favorite
doctor there you
go look there's nothing wrong with being
a pretentious hipster just realize
that's what you are that's all that I
ask
ah there's a lot of complaints about the
meeps pronouns but the third doctorine
Joe Grant did the same thing with Alpha
Centaur and Cur of Pon padon in 1972
yeah yeah I retweeted that clip
myself
uh did you see a slight uh similarity
between the mind control unit Soldier
and the star Beast and the robomen from
the doct movie do and Asian Earth 2050
ad I
mean conceptually a
little I guess visually a little too
because they put
their visors down to cover their glowing
eyes yeah I guess a little bit yeah
sure sure we'll go with
that
Supreme
Omega was Revenge of the Nerds ever
good well
um I'm gonna find out because it's not
going to be for a little while ah gaming
villager thank you for telling me I did
miss that and oh I also missed oh I
missed a couple oh you know what
happened cuz I went back to Serenity
Productions cuz I remember that being
the last one I read but serenity
Productions that come in with another
one so I missed two I I missed you and I
missed shotguns and salt so I I will do
that but yeah uh Revenge of the Nerds
I've been commissioned to to watch and
review that one so uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna find
out oh boy don't know when that's going
to happen that's that's going to be
sometime next year probably for for a
while um shotguns and salt sorry I
missed it initially I meant to say this
in the previous one whoops um but I'm so
sorry that happened I can't wait to see
your review thank you very much if you
have a VPN set it to Canada you should
be able to see the video then um and
gaming villager who is Canadian judging
by the currency I tried to make YouTube
videos once but I found I didn't enjoy
it which makes me wonder what's your
favorite part of making videos
I as you may have
guessed I like to
talk and
I have all these these things and these
thoughts and these feelings around
things that I've watched read experienc
and I want to share those
thoughts
but you know my kiddo is isn't into a
lot of um what I watch only some of my
partners are into some of the stuff I
watch and even then like you know when
we're together we're going to do
something other than just have me geek
like me geeking out is is a it's just a
thing I've always loved doing and
YouTube is how I get to do that and feel
heard feel like the the people who
actually want to hear
my um feelings on this are are GNA find
it that's what I like about
it all right coming back down to the
bottom I do need to wrap up um Wilson
Kilmer today does suck I'm right here
with you drinking cheers my friend and
cast cter
Boris interesting name what are your
predictions for wild be blue yonder I
feel like you wasted your money I don't
do
predictions um it just has to do with
the way my brain works predictions are
like I'm not going to say I never ever
but it there's a reason it's not a
regular feature on my channel because my
brain doesn't work that way um I can try
and yes but there is a very loud
screaming part in the back of my head
going just wait and watch it when it
comes out why are you wasting time
thinking about this so unless something
like fully Clicks in my
head
um uh oh my God Ser Productions I'm so
sorry oh
geez ah should have I shouldn't have had
as much as I did sorry I will get I will
get it sorry about that um but anyways
like I don't really do speculation
Because unless something really clicks
with me that I'm like o I think I know
how that might pay off or I think of how
I I might like to see that
payoff that's just not how my brain
works it's it's just not um and I can't
force it I can't force it to work that
way it's it's the same reason like I I'm
I I can't do like Theory videos or
decoding videos or deep lore you know oh
I think this is the this is the secret
history of this like I can't I can't do
that because kind of like what I said
before my brain goes none of this
matters this isn't essential information
for viewing and enjoying the thing stop
what are you doing stop wasting your
brain power on this so I'm a horrible
person to ask for speculation I have
none I am sorry Serenity
Productions have you seen Jesse's review
of the episode was wondering what you
thought of her take on the binary
non-binary line and that part and that
whole part of the episode I have not I
actually haven't seen anybody else's
review uh of it as
yet
um it's it's just I've been
busy
um so payoff how old am I I'm
um but
uh the I I I haven't seen it um I I'm
I'm sure she has uh thoughts and I I
will try and get to them at some point
but yeah no I haven't I haven't seen
hers or anybody else's uh as yet uh
opinions on Donna's mom in Star beast in
comparison to how she was in season 4
it's clear that she kept her word and
really tried to be better and more
supportful more supportive of Donna but
she still also feels like herself I
actually liked her a lot I say that as
someone who did not especially like her
in season 4 I'm not entirely sure you're
meant to like her but like I didn't
especially I liked her a lot more
here
um yeah I'm gonna wrap it
up okay thank you very much for joining
me folks this this has been this was
nice like I said big crowd good grief um
I don't I don't remember uh the last
time I had uh had an audience this big
which is which was nice and super chats
are really appreciated that helps I mean
like for the obvious financial reasons
obviously money does matter depressingly
something something capitalism bad um
but you know
it's it's reassuring and it's comforting
and
it's it's just nice so thank you I hope
that everybody has a good evening a good
rest of the day good rest of the
week um far as stuff coming up I will be
streaming on Twitch tomorrow um playing
more idots I'm also going to stream on
Friday I may or may not be playing more
than that or I might try something else
we'll see um I don't I'm not expecting
to have a video out Saturday although
now that I do not intend to actually use
footage from the show your fault BBC um
I might have the review
for um the next Doctor Who special out
on Saturday like late Saturday my time
um so folks in the UK you might get it
Sunday morning um but uh that's that's
sort of what's coming up in the
immediate so thank you very much for
joining me here um please remember that
you are beautiful you are valid and you
are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meeting
and until next time this
council is
adjourned
MAV